[拍手]
皆さんこんにちはSMLだと申します
いきなりこんないでたちの人間が現れて
びっくりされた方もいらっしゃるかもしれ
ませんがこのメイクは私にとっては一種の
仮面です
私はここ一橋大学の4年生の時今からもう
30年ぐらい前になりますけれどもその
時期に
初めてドラァグクイーンをしてショーし
ました
ドラッグクイーンというのはこういう派手
なメイクをしこのような派手な衣装を身に
まとってイベントを盛り上げたりあるいは
パフォーマンスをしたりする存在のことを
指します
ちなみにドラッグクイーンのメイクという
のは女性
らしさの象徴である化粧をわざと大げさに
することによってそしてパロディ化する
ことによって男らしさあるいは女らしさと
いった社会から押し付けられたらしさを
笑い飛ばす試みであると言われています
わざと目や口を大きめに書いたりあるいは
巨大な月末をつけたりするのはそのため
ですさて私は30年近くドラゴンとして
様々なメディアやイベントに出演しリップ
シンク
口パクのショーをしたりあるいは歌を歌っ
たりお芝居をしたりしています
そしてメイクという仮面があるからこそ私
は普段よりも少し自由にそして大胆に今も
50歳を過ぎているんですけれども50を
過ぎても様々な活動がこのメイクという
仮面のおかげでできているような気がし
ます
一方で私は大学2年生の夏まで心にある
仮面をかぶせていました
本当は
男性が好きなのにそれをずっと隠し時には
女性が好きなふりをしたりしていたんです
その仮面は今から考えると私を抑圧し
そして
萎縮させてもいました
皆さんの中にも例えばメイクをしたり
あるいはコスプレをしたりすると
普段はできないような大胆な行動が取れる
ようになるという人やいつも他人に気を
使って人に嫌われないようにして生きて
いる何かこう心に亀をかぶせているようだ
という風に感じながら生きていらっしゃる
方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
今回はそんな
仮面が私たちに与える様々な営業そして
仮面との付き合い方について私なりに考え
てみたいと思います
人は基本的には
常にその場に
応じた様々な金をかぶって生きていると私
は思っています例えば親の前では子供の
仮面子供の前では親の仮面上司の前では
部下の仮面そして部下の前では上司の仮面
といった具合にです
人はその場の状況あるいは相手との関係性
によって自分なりに最もふさわしいと判断
した仮面をかぶっているのではない
でしょうか
よくありのままの自分で生きようという
フレーズを耳にしますが本当にありのまま
で生きられる人はごくわずかだと思います
ただ
仮面というのは時に人を疲れさせ苦しめ
ます
例えばもともと大人しい人が陽気な
キャラクターの鐘をかぶる時あるいは本当
は言いたいことがたくさんあるのに
従順な金をかぶらなければいけない時
他人からよく思われたいとかあるいは少し
でも他人との摩擦を減らして社会の中で
効率よく生きていきたいとかそういった
思いがある時に人は本当はかぶりたくない
仮面あるいは自分に合わない金をかぶるの
ではないでしょうか
その結果確かに他人からよく思われたり
あるいは社会の中でこうスムーズに生きて
いくことができるかもしれませんが無理に
かぶった仮面はじわじわとその人に
ストレスを与えます
冒頭でお話ししたように私は私の場合は
ずっと
異性愛者
異性を好きな人の仮面をかぶっていました
物心ついた時から
男性が好きなという思いはあったんです
けれどもこのことは誰にも話してはいけ
ないとなぜか思い込んで本当の気持ちを
ずっと隠していました
例えば好きな人いると
尋ねられるたびに好きだった同性の同級生
の名前ではなくて
異性の同級生の名前をあげたりしていまし
たまた自分の中にある女性的な部分を
できるだけ人に悟られないようにしなけれ
ばいけないと思い込んでいましたただその
仮面をかぶり続けることができなくなった
のは大学に入学してからのことでしたそれ
まで私の身の回りには男女のカップルと
いうのもそんなにはいなかったしいつかは
自分も女性を好きになるだろうと漠然と
思っていましたところが大学に入ってから
友人たちが次々の異性と付き合うように
なる中で私自身は一向に女性を好きになる
気配はありませんでしたそしてこのままだ
ととても孤独な人生を歩むようになるので
はないかと思うようになったんです
金をかぶったまま生きることに限界を覚え
てある
ゲイのグループに連絡を取ったのは大学2
年生の夏でした
たまたま書店でそのグループが出した本を
手に取ってここは真面目な団体だし信頼
できそうだなというふうに思ったんです
そこでそのグループでたくさんのゲームの
友人ができたことがきっかけでようやく
家族や友人にカミングアウトするように
なりそこから一人の
芸大生として生きるようになりました
長年かぶり続けていた
異性愛者の加盟をそこでようやく外すこと
ができたんです
そして一度外してしまうとそれまで自分が
その金によっていかに抑圧され苦しんでい
たかがよくわかりました何も隠すことなく
好きな男性タレントの話をしたりあるいは
同性との声の話ができること
あるいはこれを好きだと言ったら女性的だ
と思われるんじゃないかなっていうそう
いうためらいがなく自分の好きなものに
ついて話すことができることその開放感と
幸福感がとても大きかったからです
それまでの人生にももちろん
楽しいことや
幸せなことはいろいろあったんですけれど
も私が本当に自分らしく生きられるように
なったのはやはり加盟を外してからでは
ないかなというふうに思いますまたある
女性に女性の友人にカミングアウトをした
時にこう言われたんです以前は何を考え
てるのかちょっとよくわからないところが
あったけどようやくどんな人なのか分かっ
た気がするそんな風に言われたんですね
彼女とは割と何でも話してこう
仲良くしてたつもりだったのでその言葉は
私にとってはとても意外でしたただ他人に
よって自分の心の何かを覆い隠すことが
知らず知らずのうちに人との間に壁を作っ
てしまうのだということに
改めてその時に気づきました
もしかしたら皆さんの中でも例えば親と
いう仮面とか子供という仮面上司という
仮面や部下という仮面そういった仮面を
かぶることによって時には本心が
覆い隠されてしまい人と人とが1人のこと
として向き合うことが
妨げられているところがあるかもしれない
と思います
画面にはこのように人を抑圧したり人と人
との距離を遠ざけたりする作用があります
でも一方で人は仮面をかぶることによって
解放されることもあります
私が初めてこういうメイクをして人前で
パフォーマンスをしたのは大学4年生の夏
でした当時という
ニューヨークのドライブインがとても
クラブシーンで人気を博していて
ゲイの友人たちのドラゴンに挑戦して
みようという話になったんです
私にはそれまでメイクをしないとか
あるいは女性の服を着たいという願望は
それほど強くはありませんでしたただ法律
の勢いでメイクをして
衣装を身につけ人前でパフォーマンスをし
たところあまりにも楽しくてそれから
しばしばドラグーンをやるようになり今で
は仕事のようになっています
ドラ学院をする目的や理由は人によって
様々です何かこう女性
綺麗な女性に近づきたいという人もいれば
何かこう目立ちたいという人を派手な格好
したいという人いろいろいるんですけれど
も私にとってはパフォーマンスをすること
が
楽しくてドラゴンをやるそれがドライブ
クイーンをやる目的です私にとってこの
メイクというのは言うなれば
パフォーマンスをするための仮面のような
ものなんです
私はもともと目立ちたがりやところがあっ
て人前で話をしたり
演技をしたり歌を歌ったりすることが
大好きでしたただ
成長するにつれてこういうことを人前で
するのは恥ずかしいと自分にブレーキを
かけることが多くなりました例えば私は昔
からテレビドラマとか舞台とかを見ていて
女性のキャラクターに感情を移入すること
が多かったんですそこでよくそんな
ヒロインの真似をしていましたまた音楽に
関しても女性のシンガーとかあるいは女性
のアーティストの楽曲の方が好きでよく
歌っていましたただ
高校生ぐらいになると男なのに女性の演技
を真似したり女性の歌を歌ったりするのは
似合わないし
恥ずかしいことではないかという風に
考えるようになって学生時代に組んでいた
バンドでは
男性アーティストの曲や中性的な女性
アーティストの曲を選んで歌っていました
ところがドラッグクイーンに挑戦してこう
いうメイクをしスカートやワンピースを身
につけハイヒールを履くそんな女性的な
ものを身につけることで人前で女性を演じ
たり女性の歌を歌ったりすることに全く
ためらいがなくなりました
また
素顔をメイクによって覆い隠すことでより
自由にのびのびとパフォーマンスが落ちる
ことができるようになりました
派手なメイクをし
普段絶対に着ないようなこういう衣装を身
につけエスムラルだという別人格の仮面を
かぶるそうすることで私は本来の自分の
性別年齢性格
容姿といったものからある程度
解放されて少し大胆で自由な自分になれて
いるような気がします
ちなみに私はエスメラルだという名前でも
本名でも文章を発表しているんですけれど
も本名の時本名で発表した文章に対しての
方が評価に関して非常にナーバスになって
しまいます
という名前で書いたものが
批判されていても何かこう他人ごとのよう
に冷静に捉えることができるんですが本名
で書いたものが同じように批判されると何
かこう長めの自分が傷つけられたような
そんな感覚に陥ります
ドラグクイーンメイクによって
素顔を覆い隠すことそして
芸名とかペンネームによって自分の本名を
隠すことそれは自分自身とは別の外的な
人格を作って
傷つきやすい生身の自分を守ることになっ
ているのではないかと思います
ただ人を解放し自由にするあるいは
傷つきやすい生身の自分を守るという仮面
の特徴が時にはネガティブな方向に作用し
作用することもあります例えば
インターネットなどでの
匿名での誹謗中傷です
昨今
巨大掲示板あるいはSNSなどによる
匿名での誹謗中傷が話題になっています
匿名というのも一つの仮面ではないかと私
は思います
国民によって開放感とかあるいは元の自分
から切り離された感覚を得るときに人は
本名では決して口にしないような言葉を全
世界に向けて発信してしまったりするので
はないでしょうか
もちろん
匿名という仮面が
完全に全ていけないわけではありません
ただ画面には良くも悪くもその人が本質的
に持っている
欲望とか本能みたいなものを増幅させ
やすい作用があるのではないでしょうか
これまで見てきたように下面には様々な
働き作用がありますそのため
仮面それ自体を一概に良い悪いと判断する
ことはできませんただ
仮面との付き合い方を考えることは誰に
とっても必要なことではないかと私は思い
ます皆さんもぜひ考えてみてください人前
で本来の自分とは違う人格や役割を演じて
いると感じる瞬間はないでしょうか
仮面をかぶっている時皆さんは気持ちが
解放されて
幸せを感じているでしょうかあるいは
抑圧されストレスを感じたり
攻撃的になったりしているでしょうか
普段自分が金をかぶって生活をしていると
いうことをちゃんと認識することそして金
の様々な作用を知ることそれができれば
仮面というものをもう少し客観的に捉える
ことができるようになるのではない
でしょうか
そうすれば自分でも気づかないうちに自分
に合わない仮面をかぶってしまうこと
あるいは仮面によって
抑圧されること
仮面の力を借りて暴走することなどが
なくなり必要に応じて金をかぶる不要な金
を外すそういったことがもっと意識的に
できるようになるのではないかと私は思い
ます
かつて私は自分がゲイであることを知ら
れることを恐れてあるいは他者に女性的だ
と思われることを恐れて少しでも男性
らしく振る舞おうとしてとてもしんどさを
感じていました
しかし今は時にはこの場面ではちょっと
男性っぽく振る舞ってみようとかこの場面
ではちょっと女性っぽく振る舞ってみよう
といった具合に自分の意志で金の付け外し
を行いそれを楽しんでいるところがあり
ます
ですから例えばプロジェクトのリーダーに
任命されて何か荷が重いなと感じた時
あるいは人に嫌われたくないからとなんと
なくいい人を演じてしまってストレスを
感じる時そういった時も今だけはリーダー
の仮面をかぶってみようとか今だけは
あえていい人の金をかぶってみようといっ
たぐらいに
意識的に金をかぶればその加盟は自分の
意志でいつでも外すことができるように
なると私は思います
仮面に飲み込まれるのではなくて
仮面と適度な距離で付き合うことそれが
可能になれば加盟をかぶることで得られる
メリットを享受しながらより幸せで
豊かな人生を歩むことができるようになる
のではないかと私は思っていますそして
今
仮面について今回お話をしましたけれども
その
仮面というのはもしかしたら
常識世間の常識と置き換えてみてもいいか
もしれないそんなふうにも思っています皆
さんご清聴本当にありがとうございました
[拍手]